WE HAVE FOX TEAM COVERAGE.
FOX BUSINESS NETWORK IS IN
NEW YORK TO TELL US WHAT
HAPPENED ON THE MARKETS.
WE BEGIN WITH CHIEF
CONGRESSIONAL CORRESPONDENT
MIKE EMANUEL ON CAPITOL HILL
WITH THE LATEST ON THE EFFORTS
TO PASS THE BUDGET DEAL TO KEEP
THE GOVERNMENT OPEN.
>> GOOD EVENING.
THE SENATE IS IN A BIT OF A
HOLDING PATTERN AS KENTUCKY
SENATOR RAND PAUL IS ON THE
SENATE FLOOR THIS HOUR
PROTESTING THE BUDGET AGREEMENT,
BREAKING EXISTING SPENDING CAPS.
A BIT OF AN EFFORT A MOMENT AGO
BY MAJORITY LEADER
MITCH MCCONNELL AND SENATE
DEMOCRATIC LEADER CHUCK SCHUMER
MOVE THINGS ALONG, NOTING TIME
IS GETTING SHORT.
SENATOR PAUL OBJECTED.
HE IS MAKING HIS CASE NOW.
AHEAD OF VOTES IN THE SENATE AND
EVENTUALLY THE HOUSE, THERE’S
BEEN SOME SERIOUS PUSHBACK.
>> GOING TO HAVE THIS MUCH OF AN
INCREASE IN SPENDING AND ALMOST
NOTHING IN THE WAY OF PAY FORS.
I LIKE BIPARTISANSHIP.
IT SEEMS LIKE WE COULD DO IT IN
A BIPARTISAN WAY.
>> DEFICIT HAWKS EXPRESS THEIR
DISGUST.
THE BUDGET PACKAGE INCLUDES MORE
SPENDING ON THE MILITARY.
DEMOCRATS DEMANDED $131 BILLION
MORE, NEARLY DOLLAR FOR DOLLAR
COME IN DOMESTIC SPENDING, AND
ERASE THE DEBT CEILING THROUGH
MARCH -- A RAISE OF THE DEBT
CEILING.
>> HE IS CONCERNED ABOUT
SPENDING IN WASHINGTON.
LET ME SAY WE DO SUPPORT THE
TWO-YEAR SPENDING BILL THAT’S
BEING DISCUSSED AND VOTED ON IN
THE HOUSE AND SENATE.
IT LIFTS THE CAPS ON DEFENSE
SPENDING.
>> PACKAGE INCLUDES $90 BILLION
IN DISASTER RELIEF MONEY FOR
HURRICANE VICTIMS IN TEXAS,
FLORIDA, PUERTO RICO.
MONEY FOR WILDFIRE VICTIMS IN
CALIFORNIA.
SENATE LEADERS FOCUSED ON
GETTING IT DONE.
>> I’M CONFIDENT KNOWS HOW TO
TURN EITHER SIDE OF THE AISLE
BELIEVES THIS IS A PERFECT BELT
BUT I’M ALSO CONFIDENT THIS IS
OUR BEST CHANCE TO BEGIN
REBUILDING OUR MILITARY AND MAKE
PROGRESS ON ISSUES DIRECTLY
AFFECTING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> LEADING SENATE DEMOCRAT
CALLED THIS TO YOUR BUDGET OF
BREAKTHROUGH.
>> FOR TOO LONG, THIS GRIDLOCKED
CONGRESS HAS LURCHED FROM ONE
CONTINUING RESOLUTION, TO
ANOTHER.
IT’S PREVENTED US FROM WORKING
TOGETHER TO CRAFT APPROPRIATIONS
BILLS THAT SAVE TAXPAYERS MONEY.
>> ON THE HOUSE SIDE, DEMOCRATIC
LEADER NANCY PELOSI NEGOTIATED
THE AGREEMENT BUT SPOKE OUT
AGAINST IT BECAUSE A DEAL FOR
THE SO-CALLED DREAMERS IS NOT
INCLUDED.
>> DON’T SAY TO THE HOUSE